here's our panel he's president of the
Robin Hood Foundation and the New York
Times bestselling author of five days
the fiery reckoning of an American city
Westmore back with us by zoom hey Wes
he's an MSNBC political analyst and
co-host of the weekly podcast 20/20
politics war room the great sage of the
Democratic Party James Carville
James great to see you great to see you
both I do see you through that little
lens there okay so let's start with the
big story Biden has a 14-point lead over
Donald Trump and not just the usual
suspects obviously winning big with
young people minorities women but also
college-educated but also some of the
people we wouldn't have suspected I mean
suburban white women doing well men
suburban men the military not too crazy
about him nowadays in North Carolina
there was a primary Tuesday the moderate
who Trump was against beat the other guy
that Trump was for by 32 points I've
never been this optimistic James let me
start with the obvious question how are
the Democrats going to blow it I don't
know we can do it let's get up in the
middle of the night now said now okay
look he's beaten he's feeble
he's frail frail he's a failure he's fat
he's going to think of the next up word
that you want you know jumping out the
question is not just to beat Trump we
have to eradicate Trump isn't the idea
that Wes Moore in my children are
fighting over a define thing as opposed
to an expanded view of what the country
in the world is and right now we could
beat your business Trump beating forget
it he's done no Jane
but we got to win big enough that the
Republican Party never wants to embrace
this kind of toxic philosophy again what
worries you Wes about this I mean it
looks so good right now what what's on
your mind
that is troubling voter suppression
Georgia Georgia better get it back
together Kentucky had a primary it went
actually pretty doggone well Georgia is
over to an election and they gotta get
their acts break because anything in
Georgia we don't win the prize but they
gonna try to do everything they can to
stop people from voting
everything they can to have foreign
influence influence on their on their
side they're gonna do all of that we are
on guard all right we're posting
sentries all over this country there's
so many lawyers around there you
wouldn't believe
well they get it to us in 16 you know
dr-dos just in 20 what we're up and
running and ready to go here bill I'm
serious worried about winning just not
worried about winning big okay well no
but but actually I think you do need to
worry about winning and there and the
reason I say that is is this is the
election is still five months away you
know when we think about it look at
where we were five months ago and I
don't think anyone could have predicted
five months ago that we'd be where we
are right now
you know we saw that the election in
2016 was a cataclysmic event in American
history the corona virus has been a
cataclysmic event in American history in
world history the moment we're seeing
right now for black lives a cataclysmic
event in American history and so I
actually at four I actually don't think
that November is any form of a slam dunk
because the reality is it's still five
months away we have to be so deliberate
on the points that you brought up James
on making sure that we're doing two
things every single day going into these
the rest of this year one is making sure
that we're preserving the right to vote
but also to making sure we're giving
people something to vote for because
that's gonna do those patches right
there are going to determine how this
election goes and what things look like
the day after election day yeah a bar
the Attorney General said foreign
countries can easily make counterfeit
ballots what that means I don't know how
they would do it I don't know how they
get them in the election even if you saw
them wouldn't you
see the real ballot and then know
something was afoot it seems to me like
these guys do know that they can't be
beat there too many partners have
flooded on the Titanic this is going to
go down and their only way is to cheat
you see it that way
I do absolutely it's the only chance
very captain boys captain um corporal
so you outrank me but I got I got some
strike them from campaign but that's of
course they gonna do that in the reason
that bar saying that is because they
don't want to do mail in balance because
they're scared people are gonna vote
right that's what behind all of this
you